[Music]
beginning in the third century before
the common era the romans conquered the
iberian peninsula this period gave rise
to several regional languages in the
area that's now spain including
castilian catalan and galician
one of this would become spanish but not
for another 1500 years those years tell
the origin story of what's become a
global modern language
during the roman occupation colloquial
spoken latin often called vulgar latin
mixed with indigenous languages
approximately 75 of modern spanish comes
from latin including syntactic rules
for instance verbs are conjugated in a
similar way as in latin and like other
roman languages nouns have gender
el sol the sun is masculine whereas la
luna the moon is feminine
after the roman empire collapsed a
series of other powers conquered the
region
first came the visigoths starting in the
5th century of the common era they spoke
an eastern germanic language that would
eventually become part of german and
lent a few words to the language that
would become spanish
then the umayyad caliphate ousted the
visigoths
they spoke arabic which left a strong
mark on modern spanish over a thousand
words come from arabic
these often have a starting a or z sound
and sometimes include an
in 1492 the catholic church consolidated
its power through two monarchs isabella
and ferdinand expelling muslims and jews
combining the distinct regional kingdoms
into one nation and adopting one of the
local languages as the official state
language
that language was castellano or
castilian from the kingdom of castile
which was centrally located in spain and
home to madrid
thereafter castellano became espanol or
spanish
but the spanish of 1492 was old spanish
very different from spanish today
that same year christopher columbus
sailed across the atlantic ocean marking
the start of the spanish conquest of the
americas
the indigenous population of the
americas spoke an estimated 2 000
different languages over the next few
decades most of them were forced to
adopt spanish at the expense of their
own languages
still words from indigenous languages
became part of spanish from naguatl the
language of the aztec empire came words
with chu
ch and
wai like chapulin and coyote
from quechua a language spoken in the
peruvian andes came words with ch
like kancha chuyo and poncho
some of these words describe things that
hadn't existed in the spanish lexicon
before while others replaced existing
spanish words even in spain
by the time miguel de cervantes
published the first part of don quixote
in 1605 the language was arguably more
similar to modern spanish than place of
one of his contemporaries william
shakespeare were to modern english
starting in the 18th century french
language and culture were extremely
fashionable in spain and later hispanic
america
while the two languages already had
commonalities from their shared roots in
latin
spanish gained new words from french
during this period
in the 19th century all over central and
south america people revolted to gain
independence from spain
in the newly sovereign nations people
continued to speak the language of their
former oppressors
today there are approximately 415
million inhabitants of hispanic america
spanish is the official language of 21
countries in puerto rico as of 2021 only
english mandarin and hindi have more
speakers
how does a language with so many
speakers around the world not break
apart into new languages the way vulgar
latin did
there's no easy answer to this question
other languages that spread through
colonialism like french have mixed with
indigenous languages to form entirely
new ones
some would argue that spanglish a
mixture of spanish and english is a
distinct language or on its way to
becoming one
but although a person in buenos aires
occasionally might use words that aren't
fully intelligible to someone in bogota
or mexico city
spanish retains enough unity of syntax
grammar and vocabulary to remain one
language
habla espanol want to see your favorite
animations in spanish check out ted ed
in espanol a channel dedicated to
bringing our library of lessons worth
sharing to spanish-speaking communities
around the world click here to learn
more and make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss a single video stay tuned and
stay curious